- A long time ago,
humanity Rose to become
the dominant species
on planet earth.
And we were able to do this
because of one specific trait.
It certainly it wasn't
our physical prowess,
pretty much any animal
the same size as us would
absolutely destroy us
in a one-on-one physical altercation.
And it wasn't even our
ability to use tools
because that's not unique to humans.
We were able to rise to power
because of a specific development
in the cerebral cortex.
That of abstract thought
the ability to conceptualize
predict, and plan for the future.
Unlike any other animal human
beings, weren't just concerned
with what they were going to eat today
but also what they were
going to eat tomorrow
and weeks from now and years from now.
It was this instinct
of future preservation,
that allowed us to ration our food.
Start to predict changes in seasons.
We became the only animal in history,
that was able to consciously
forego present pleasure
in order to pave the
way for a better future.
And while this trait was perhaps
the single greatest survival
mechanism we ever developed.
I'd also argue it's the very reason,
why it's so difficult to be happy.
Because the world is modernized,
technology advanced so much
faster than we did as humans.
We live in this super advanced world,
yet we're still packing
around primal hardware.
It's in our very nature to
be constantly fantasizing
about an ideal future.
We'll work jobs that we
don't like, grind away today.
So that will eventually
achieve prosperity tomorrow.
Maybe if you're a student,
you're grinding through school today,
so you can eventually get the
degree, get a well-paying job.
Maybe find the love of your life.
Human beings are really
good at postulating.
What might be in the future
and using the present to
prepare for that moment.
And I'm not saying that's a bad thing.
It's an extremely useful thing.
It's a very motivating thing.
We need to have some sort of
goal and direction in our life
otherwise we're completely
goalless and directionless.
I mean, sometimes it's
kind of weird being human
because not only do we
exist in the present moment
and have to do our day to day things
or duties and responsibilities,
but we also psychologically exist
at the exact same time
in this abstract future,
in this abstract potential,
that we ourselves generated.
And a lot of the time
it's this abstraction,
that motivates us to
get through our present
especially if our present is something
that we don't generally
like interacting with.
But the problem we run into is the fact
that there is another sensation
that is universal to
human beings, world wide.
And that is the fact
that we only experienced
life in the present moment.
We prepare for a future
that we will actually
never get to experience.
And if we place too many
cards in the future basket,
at the dramatic expense
of the present moment.
Then our entire lives can end
up looking like a squirrel,
obsessively, hoarding acorns
in preparation for a
winter that never comes.
Which seems in a way like
we're constantly postponing
our own happiness.
And that can be extremely exhausting.
Especially if you've been doing that
for years and years and
perhaps even decades.
It's almost like every single
person who has ever lived
and who will ever live.
If left unchecked will
hamster wheel themselves
right into their graves.
So what's the solution to this problem.
I'd be really demoralizing
me coming here and saying,
you will never achieve your dreams.
Your dreams are just an abstraction.
You will never get what you want.
But that's not true.
There is a way to be
optimistic about the future,
and still have ambition.
Yet still be able to take
some of that future happiness,
into the present moment.
And I propose that the
way that that's possible
is through gratefulness.
Now, maybe you've heard this 1000 times.
Maybe you've heard that
gratefulness is a really good idea
and I should just be
grateful for what I have,
but how can I do that?
If my surroundings are
honestly kind of shitty
and I understand this feeling completely.
It's not easy to be grateful at all.
Especially if you're an ambitious person.
In fact, I would say the
more ambitious you are,
the harder it is to be grateful.
Because being grateful is actually risky.
You risk neutering yourself
of the drive to push forward,
to trend your life in an upward direction.
If you spend your life
dreaming of cookies,
then gratefulness can often feel
like you're forcing yourself
to no longer want the cookie,
but you want to want the cookie
because that increases your
chances of getting the cookie.
But I think that's the wrong
way to look at gratefulness.
Gratefulness doesn't stop
you from getting cookies.
It just helps you realize that the cookies
aren't all in front of you,
they're kind of all around you.
And you're more than welcome
to take one out and eat one.
So about a year and a half ago,
my mom started to develop a
pretty severe case of insomnia.
She's always been a very naturally
anxious person that kind
of runs in the family.
But we started to go through
some hard times the family,
and this anxiety really turned into
a really, really bad case of insomnia.
It wasn't just going on for days,
but it was weeks and weeks and weeks
of just barely any sleep at all.
Anyone who's had or severe
case of insomnia will know,
that you start to become
terrified of the nighttime.
Because you know that
you'll just be sitting there
with your own terrifying thoughts
not being able to go to sleep.
So this was going on for weeks
and I was starting to
become extremely concerned
for her mental health.
One day she messaged me and said,
"I finally been able to get
some good night's rest."
And I was so relieved.
And it turns out she didn't
use any heavy pharmaceuticals
or there were no magic pills involved.
All she did was every single night
before she put her head on the pillow,
she listed three things.
One, something that
made her smile that day.
Two, something that she's grateful for.
And three something that she did well.
She started doing this every single night.
And it's crazy to think,
that just simply reflecting on
the good things in her life.
That her frantically busy and noisy brain,
was able to calm down.
And she was finally able to get the rest
that she so desperately needed.
And she didn't just start
doing this randomly.
This is all based on
a study that she read.
I'll put the link in the description.
You guys can check it out.
I guess what I'm trying
to say is that gratitude.
It gets you out of your head.
You stop existing in the what ifs.
And if this happens then that,
or maybe this bad thing
happened in the past,
and maybe I can get
this done in the future.
You start to really look to the present,
and the good things that
are already in here.
And I'd argue that by
practicing habitual fullness.
It doesn't stop you from getting
the things that you want.
You still want the things that you want
that primal instinct is not going away.
But what it does do is
it gives you permission
to pull some of that future happiness,
into the present moment.
Because if you're never
happy with what you have
you will never be happy with what you get.
Every single night before you
put your head on your pillow,
write three good things.
Something that made you smile,
something that you're grateful for,
and something that you did well.
And this might be
difficult to see at first
and the harder it is to see at first,
the worst you are at it.
But I promise you you'll get better.
And as you get better and better
at identifying the good
things in your life,
you'll come to realize just how many
of them there are.
Videos like these are made possible,
thanks to amazing
sponsors like Skillshare.
As you guys all know,
one of my goals in life,
is to become a better
cinematographer and filmmaker.
And thankfully, there are so
many classes on Skillshare,
that are directly related to that pursuit.
I've recently started taking
this color grading class
which has really helped take
my editing to the next level.
And it helps me tell stories,
like the ones that I've
told in this video.
Helps me get my message across better.
And for those of you who don't know,
Skillshare, is an online
learning community.
With thousands of classes,
covering dozens of topics.
Everything from photography
to cinematography,
to even cooking and
coding, entrepreneurship.
Whatever your interests are,
there's something to learn on Skillshare.
And one of my favorite
things about Skillshare
is that all of their classes
are designed for real life.
So you can always take
whatever you're learning on Skillshare
and apply it directly to
your real life pursuits.
There's also so many
familiar faces on Skillshare,
like this guy and this
guy, and even this guy.
And Skillshare is also
extremely affordable
especially when you compare it to
in-person classes and workshops.
If you get the annual membership
it comes in at less than $10 a month.
Skillshare is doing this awesome thing
where if you use my link
in the description below,
you click it and you get a free trial
of Skillshare premium.
Which means that right now
no matter what you're into,
you can be watching any class you want
on Skillshare absolutely free.
So make sure you take
advantage of that link,
learn something new,
explore your creativity.
And as usual have a great time.
Guys, thank you so much for watching.
If you liked this video
make sure you hit like,
because when you hit like
the algorithm blesses me.
And it shoves my bald head
into other people's homepages,
helping them out, which also helps me out.
So it's kind of a win-win for everybody.
If you're lurking here
and this is the thousandth time
you've seen my bald head
said bald too many times,
then make sure that you hit subscribe.
And hit the bell icon so that
you don't miss future videos.
Other than that, there's a new
video coming out very soon.
Again thank you so much for watching,
and we'll catch you in the next video.
(soft music)